yeah welcome to this video bit of a late
start of the recording had some
technical issue this being the first
game of a session playing a little panda
hard to tell Egypt alright so the Kings
Indian type of formation with 97 ER 97
is an interesting way to to play this
but it's slightly risky so did Utley now
black cam is basically yep supposed to
player at five is this position I think
it is where I can play G form after
capturing G fight play Knight h2 and
captured gphone leading to the position
where black always has to worry about
his bed Bishop f4 is also possible but
not particularly great get this assume
giving me the force Graham
it's not there necessarily awful but
yeah but tricky for black to play the
the only a counter play black has in
this position is some at one point to
push before as possible but of course I
put a knight on e4 and the main counter
plays Bishop g7 I drew care for just
sacrificing the exchange this is the
only plan for black everything else
really is rather depressing hmm okay can
take and take the six month not sure why
I shouldn't some counter player maybe
with a 96-94 but I still need to take so
no no big alternatives here hmm yeah
should I just just take I wonder just
just Queen d6 probably know if he takes
on d6 place 94 I can't even clever
should be one that's not that's quite ok
with jettison jettisoning all the points
know him not sure this is really
necessary of it I don't see why I
shouldn't take them
yeah just two points up really 94 is the
counter play maybe yeah maybe this is
something okay I'm not sure though it
should be enough for 42 pounds in to
cover c2 and play Bishop e3 and he
really needs some dramatic some dramatic
moves now to to make this play ball you
can play Knight f3 maybe and if i take
rook takes the g4 pawn this is quite
weak this might be an issue yeah if it's
my move I can consider look age 32
caliber f3 Brooke age 32 to d3 something
like this activating the rook of course
just Bishop e3 is playable as well just
attacking the the night yeah he's
investing lots of time you can try
Bishop glk Bishop g4 he wants to go to
see success and an interesting idea
yeah still Nets let's attack the bishop
him at the night iam for you plays
Knight f3 how it doesn't mm-hmm just
step out of this
check yeah I need to take prompt yet
probably I do that don't really want to
spend the time to protect the pawn seems
to slow to me Brooke g1 or something I
want to play I looked he won he can take
only 3 hey I wanted to play rugby 126
it's not working ok where I can't first
played this and he takes h55 rook h1 and
if he drops it back to be six for
example i play work T 1 and rock the
sixth the IDM yeah this looks quite ok
whoopsie 800 SF 46 rook c8 b3 b5 of d6
something like this should be ok c5 you
can take this is a problem because of
the spin I have this temples
which is quite useful okay 64 for
instance if you takes your phone I can
take a seven and play be film
and before next giving me to protected
passed pawns rook rook the eighth they
are up the eighth is some counter play
hmm yeah
maybe I threatening to take with check
okay yeah I need to do this then no
nothing else look t3m need to go to be
phone yeah yeah I thought whoops you one
just taking this the spawn hope I'm not
them screwing this up here then I don't
don't really see something for him but
and she's free
hmm yeah maybe you look III would have
been better okay g3 but I can nor I
cannot
hmm yeah quite quite an annoyance this
I could have just rope she won I can
still play g3 I can move it but then is
godrick f4 check okay come on I really
don't see a great great reply yeah I
still have phone have this disappoints I
think it's it's it's okay for white I
mean winning but I'm not one hundred
percent sure I had I had seen this right
at the beginning when I wasn't sure that
I really needed to do that but it seems
to it seems to be enough though b7 was
also possible okay eight and just
queening that's hard to pretend
black for this one time it was it was a
bit bit strange to hear think it was it
was quite ok b-52 check and maybe here
we had just be six the kavita just wants
to push push to be ponyo maybe just why
not just promote yourself yeah ok and I
know b6 was also winning but this seems
to win as well yeah the computer
actually says that what is clearly
better here as well but did some
obviously not so I'm so clear as soon
before he really got a bit of a bit of
play em ok there was also Bishop takes
d4 in this position but they didn't
think it's really it's really on here
this one I thought I could just take
actually yeah something like this
nobody's got Luke a six it's maybe not
entirely clear something like this
capoten the night it should be good for
white really am it is probably good for
what alright thanks for watching